T
THAT.
THANKS SO MUCH, CONGRESSMAN FOR
COMING ON THE PROGRAM.
LAST NIGHT WE TOLD YOU HOW
KAMALA HARRIS IS TIRED OF
WORKING ON THE BORDER AND HOW
SHE WANTS A BETTER PORTFOLIO AND
CAN YOU BLAME HER?
SHE JUST SAW THE CARAVAN OF
MIGRANTS MARCHING TOWARD
AMERICA.
WHO WANTS TO DEAL WITH THAT?
BUT HAVE NO FEAR, REVEREND AL IS
HERE.
THAT'S RIGHT AL SHARPTON IS
TAKING HIS BULL HORN TO
WASHINGTON TO TELL GOOD OLD JOE
TO BUILD BACK BETTER WITH
KAMALA.
IN AN INTERVIEW SHARPTON SAYS HE
WILL TELL BIDEN HE WANTS TO SEE
KAMALA BEING USED MORE
EFFECTIVELY.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
SOMEHOW SOMETIMES LESS IS MORE.
JOE CON CHAT HILL MEDIA
COLUMNIST AND KIRA DAVIS IS THE
HOST OF JUST LISTEN TO YOURSELF
PODCAST AND BOTH OF THEM ARE
GOOD FRIENDS.
KARA, I'M GOING TO GO TO YOU
FIRST.
EVERYTHING THAT THE PRESIDENT
GIVES KAMALA, SHE FAILS AT.
WHY DIVIF HER MORE?
MAYBE SHE NEEDS TO BACK OFF A
LITTLE BIT.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY ANYONE
IS GIVING KAMALA OR NOT GIVING
KAMALA ANYTHING.
ISN'T SHE LIKE ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE WORLD?
>> Lawrence: TRUE.
>> I WOULD BE GROSSLY INSULTED
IF MY PASTOR AND MY BOSS MET
WITHOUT ME TO DISCUSS WAYS THAT
I COULD DO MY JOB BETTER.
I MEAN, WHAT -- HOW INSULTING
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND HERE'S
WHAT I THINK, LAWRENCE, I THINK
KAMALA HAS THE WORST ADVISERS IN
THE WORLD MAYBE ONLY PARALLELLED
BY JOE BIDEN.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT GIVES YOU
ANY KIND OF POSITION OF POWER TO
SEND THIS GRIFTER IN TO
NEGOTIATE FOR YOU FOR YOUR JOB
WHEN YOU ARE THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES?
JUST PICK A JOB AND DO.
CAN'T DO THE JOB SHE H I'M WITH
YOU.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW THIS HELPS
TO HAVE AL SHARPTON MARCHING UP
TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND BOSSING
JOE BIDEN AROUND.
>> Lawrence: I'M ALWAYS
SURPRISED BY THIS BY CAMERA, THE
FIRST CANDIDATE OUT OF THE
PRIMARY.
DEMOCRAT VOTERS REJECTED HER.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE IS
A ENTIRE GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT IS
PULLING FOR HER TO BE THE FACE
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BECAUSE WE ALREADY KNOW WE MAY
NOT SEE JOE BIDEN ON THE NEXT
TICKET, RIGHT?
>> GREAT POINT.
SHE SUPPOSED TO BE PLAN B.
I LOVE HOW SHE IS CALLED 2020
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
GOOD POINT, LAWRENCE.
SHE DIDN'T GET TO 2020.
DIDN'T GET TO IOWA BECAUSE SHE
WAS POLLING SO POORLY.
SHOULD THE VICE PRESIDENT SHOW
SHE COULD DO ONE JOB WELL BEFORE
GIVEN MORE JOBS IN THIS
SITUATION?
BECAUSE 23% OF AMERICANS APPROVE
OF THE WAY THE CRISIS THAT IS A
CATASTROPHE IS BEING HANDLED AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU WILL NEVER GUESS WHO WAS PUT
IN CHARGE OF THAT.
AS YOU SAID BEFORE AND BY THE
WAY IT'S NOT FRANK HARRIS IT'S
KAMALA HARRIS AND SEE IT
FIRSTHAND, AND YOU HAVE SPOKEN
TO BORDER PATROL AND HEAR THE
SAME THING.
WE ARE GETTING NO HELP FROM
WASHINGTON.
THE PRESIDENT AND V.P. DO NOT
CARE.
HERE IS SHARPTON SAYING GIVE HER
MORE RESPONSIBILITY.
MAYBE WE COULD PUT HER IN CHARGE
OF A CRIME TASK FORCE HOW DOES
THAT SOUND TO REVERSE
SKYROCKETING VIOLENT CRIME IN
AMERICAN CITIES.
THAT'S RIGHT, SHE ADVOCATED A
BAIL FUND FOR RIOTERS IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
ONE MAN WHO GOT OUT HAS SINCE
BEEN CHARGED WITH MURDER.
I GUESS THAT'S OUT.
LOOK, SHE HASN'T DONE A
ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEW WITH ANY
MAJOR ENTITY IN NEARLY 140 DAYS,
THE VIP, THE VP HERE SHE IS
COMPLETELY MIA AND THAT'S LOL
AND EXCEPT IT'S REALLY NOT.
BECAUSE SHE IS AS VISIBLE AT
THIS POINT AS MICHAEL AVENATTI
THESE DAYS.
SO, YEAH, THE REVEREND THINK
SHE'S SHOULD HAVE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Lawrence: KARA, PART OF THE
THINGS THAT IS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS THEY ARE BRINGING ALL
THESE CONSULTANTS IN.
I CAN GIVE YOU ADVICE, GIVE A
DAMN.
SHOW UP AND DO YOUR JOB.
FIX THE ISSUES AND THEN GO UP IN
THE POLLS.
>> RIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE END GAME
WAS HERE WHEN THEY BROUGHT
KAMALA TO THE WHITE HOUSE, BUT I
MEAN, AT THE END OF THE DAY, I
WOULDN'T PUT THIS WOMAN IN
CHARGE OF MY GROCERY SHOPPING
LET ALONE ANY MAJOR ISSUES.
I'M TRYING TO IMAGINE WHAT
NEGOTIATIONS AL SHARPTON IS
MAKING WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO NEGOTIATE ON
HER BEHALF.
IF YOU HAVE GOT TO SEND IN A GUY
LIKE AL SHARPTON WHOSE JOB IS
LITERALLY TO SELL FAVORITISM.
IT'S LITERALLY TO SELL FAVORS,
THAT'S A BIG INDICATION THAT YOU
ARE REALLY NOT CUTTING IT AT
YOUR JOB.
>> Lawrence: I WOULD TELL YOU,
THIS KIRA, YOU MAY NOT HAVE
GROCERIES FOR HER TO PICK UP.
>> I